- Let's close out this
hour with one more nugget
sure to bring you some joy.
This is what I'm liking
(upbeat music)
so usually I share a cute
video from social media
or a story that will melt your heart,
or that's what we're trying to do
today though, I'm liking
an awesome TV show.
that's coming back for its ninth
season this Thursday night.
So people are watching, I'm
talking about the black list,
which ended with a huge twist last season
(audience cheer)
It was a big one.
We have one of the stars of
the show on the line right now.
So let's everybody say hi to Amir Arison
(audience cheering)
- Hello
Hi
- [Kelly Clarkson] What's up man
So season eight ended
with the shocking death
of one of the main characters.
so what are we to expect this next season?
- So, yeah, it was crazy.
we lost one of our beloved
central cast members,
and with her death, with
the tragedy that unfolded,
the writers have done
something extraordinary.
It was like, how are we
going to pick up after that?
and really where we're picking up
is actually two years later,
and so what they've done is
they've taken each character
and imagined what they
would have gone through,
not just right after,
but where they've grown,
where they've changed,
where they're in pain and
what has become to them.
Of course, our lead character,
Raymond Reddington played
by James Spader is missing.
And it's like,
how are we going to draw
him back out into the fold
to catch more black listers?
- Oh my Gosh. There's such great writers.
That's really good, man.
Okay. Well, I understand
that you want to give
a special shout out to
someone, so who is it?
- So thank you for asking
Myrna Feldman is my
third grade teacher
and my drama teacher and director
from grades three through nine.
And
I deci..
I realized I wanted to be an actor
in the sixth grade after doing a play.
I knew that's what I was gonna do.
And she encouraged me
the whole way through
and to this day, I mean,
that was after she came
and visited me after
a play I had done,
oh, Reiner wants to go down
A play I had done in New York city
and to this day,
she emails me after every few episodes,
what she loved about the episode,
how proud she is of me and,
and her and her family.
She likes us to call her
auntie Mame. And yeah,
so a big shout out to Myrna
because she changed a lot of
people's lives.
Big shout out to the
teachers, and honestly,
a shout out to all of the dance teachers,
art teachers, drama
teachers, music teachers,
- [Kelly Clarkson] Choir
teachers yeah, yeah ,yeah
- I think arts access arts
asses, as you well know,
arts access and education
can be as important as
math, science, history, sports.
It's essential.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah, no
- She changed my life
- We love teachers here.
You've come to the right place.
All right, everybody season
nine of the blacklist premieres
October 21st at 8:00 PM. Eastern on NBC.
Thank you so much Amir,
I'm liking your post
All right, all right
Well usually, At this point in the show,
we give our guests a thousand dollars
courtesy of pilot friction, erasable pen,
the go to pen at the Kelly Clarkson show,
but we're going to mix it up today y'all
and you were lucky because someone
has that check under their seat right now.
So go ahead and take a
look who has the check?
thousand dollars. Who's got it.
Ohhh you got it.
Woahhhhh
All right all right, way to go, stand up.
What's your name?
- I'm Olivia,
- Olivia, what are you going to do
with your thousand dollars?
- Maybe help with school, I go to USC.
- That's awesome.
- So help with some school. Yeah
- Spend a little bit into something fun.
- [Olivia] Yeah
- Little bit on school,
little bit on something fun
That's awesome. Congratulations.
- Thank you so much.